European commission president Ursula
Fonda line is in Ukraine for the third
time since the start of the war her
visit comes as Russia launches more
attacks on Ukrainian soil including a
missile strike on a reservoir near
President Vladimir silenski's hometown
it's a week since Ukraine's
counter-offensive saw Russian troops
Retreat from parts of the Northeast
Ukraine since the War Began also a
thunder line received a warm welcome
from president volodimir zielinski and
an award for her commitment to EU
Ukraine relations among the talking
points the 8 million plus people who
fled to EU countries since the War Began
in February
we want of course to have our to give
our Ukrainian friends when they need
help as much support as possible
but we also know that they are longing
to go home again
even as Fonda lines night train made its
way to Kiev Russian Rockets struck a
reservoir Dam in criviri an industrial
center and president zielinski's
hometown
the resulting flood inundated several
roads and houses and the local drinking
water supply was cut
the drains aren't working and we can't
flush the toilet everything's flooded
and there's been no one from the
disaster Protection Agency here since
yesterday evening
president zielinski said the Russian
strikes on the city so close to his
roots had no military value and zelenski
said that fact shows Russia is intent on
attacking Ukrainian civilians
hakif is the second largest city in
Ukraine despite being only 40 kilometers
from the Russian border Ukraine's
military has kept the Russians from
occupying it but the city has faced
Relentless artillery fire since the War
Began
this is hakif's Regional Council
building it was struck by a Russian
missile in early March leaving only its
facade standing six months on
construction work is underway the rest
of the city center also Bears the scars
of indiscriminate daily shelling that
and the intense artillery panels that
continued into the summer prompted
thousands of civilians to flee the once
thriving City
I spoke to DW correspondent Nick
Connelly who's following the latest
developments for us from hakif I asked
him about the situation in the city
well as you can probably see behind me
there is very little of kharkiv to be
seen at a pretty early evening hour
because lots of people it often feels in
a sense like the majority have left and
the ones who are remaining are sticking
to all the recommendations keeping their
curtains firmly shut and basically
keeping off the streets pretty
extraordinary to be a city of more than
a million and a half and occasionally
only to see some cars passing a distance
a few very rare pedestrians but it's a
real contrast to the times before this
war started I was here in mid-February
when the U.S government said that the
war was imminent and people here just
couldn't get their heads around it they
couldn't believe that this was on the
cards and this was a thriving City with
also tens of thousands of foreign
students coming here from around the
world who also took their cue from the
locals and were convinced that being 40
kilometers away from Russia didn't
necessarily mean that they were in
danger now since this Ukrainian assault
counter-offensive in the East Northeast
of the country has done so well we've
seen some Russian retaliation attacks
we've seen attacks on the energy
infrastructure on the power system the
heating system rather and
extraordinarily it's proved pretty uh
flexible and resilient and able to
restore those systems for the most part
power is back the Metro is operating and
even though you know as I mentioned so
many people have left those remaining
are keeping the show on the road but the
question looking now towards the next
few months is even if Russian forces are
no longer in this part of the country
they are still only as you mentioned
their 40 comes away on their own
territory so the risk of attacks of
missile attacks of long distance through
that is still very much there yesterday
evening we heard a big explosion in the
downtown not far from our hotel and the
air raid sirens only came on about three
four minutes after itself and it's so
difficult to really tell when these
things are coming and they're coming
from such a short distance that the
systems here just can't really give
anyone a feeling of safety or you know
the real chance to get to a position
where they can you know be protected
from damage so it is a very edgy
situation in a city that doesn't really
quite know yet whether to believe uh
that the situation is genuinely safer
and whether it's gonna have time to go
back to some kind of normality and Nick
I believe you've been to the Border
region with Russia north of hakive where
Russian troops only pulled out a matter
of days ago uh tell us more about what
you saw
well this was uh an area that is as you
mentioned they're so close to the border
and where you can still hear artillery
fire pretty much every 10-15 minutes
those battles are still going on there
and people the people who had remained
in those Villages were kind of Dazed and
kind of shocked to see Outsiders they'd
have been cut off from the outside world
or at least from kharkiven from Ukraine
control territory for six months so the
Russian army basically turned up there
within the first few hours of this war
and people there talking about
rebuilding their houses time and time
again uh one older woman we spoke to had
just about rebuilt her roof when just a
couple of days before the Ukrainian
Force came back her house was basically
destroyed and she's now trying to work
out where she's going to spend the
winter people telling us of being taken
to uh sellers to being being mistreated
by the Russian authorities because they
have family ties to people serving in
the Ukrainian Army one man we saw were
just recovering some medals that belong
to relatives Ukrainian army medals that
he'd hidden to make sure that the
Russians didn't know about quite how
illustrious his relative's career had
been people who had disappeared who
still haven't been found or heard of for
months and we even saw the what we were
told were the remains of some Ukrainian
soldiers who died there pretty much
early on in this War and who the Russian
authorities hadn't buried a censor so
that the Russian forces there had left
in great haste uh bits of tech uh
armored vehicles dumped paperwork even
we saw a drawing from seemingly the
child of one of the Russian soldiers
there sent to the father who was serving
in Ukraine with that Zed symbol that
we've seen on all those Russian troop
troop cars so a real sense that this was
an area that really was abandoned yet
great haste and there's definitely the
suspicion from lots of people on the
ground there are still Russian forces
Russian soldiers hiding in abandoned
houses who just basically didn't manage
to get out in time and are now trying to
find some way of getting out without
being caught
that was DW's Nick Connelly reporting
from the Ukrainian city of hakif